an exhibition that highlights digital
art has chosen las vegas
for its third location prepare yourself
the museum of dream space is now
open at the grand canal shops and it
promises
stunning designs for art lovers that may
be you wait till you see some of this
stuff
hector mejia is live at the venetian
with a behind the scenes look
show us all around hector it looks
really cool
and it really is cool good morning to
you sherry this is where it all begins
this is the first room and the whole
idea is for you to not only enjoy the
art exhibits but also
take hundreds or even thousands of
pictures if you'd like so you don't need
a filter here
so this is the first room this is the
gold room where
uh you see a lot of different shapes on
the wall and
on the other side over in that direction
that is the tropical room off to the
right we have a rotating
beautiful full moon where you can keep
on taking those pictures and off to the
left
we have another beautiful room this is
uh full of hundreds of
edison light bulbs looks like hundreds
of them because the walls look like they
are mirrors so it sort of multiplies
the number of light bulbs here and over
in that direction that is the tropical
room we were speaking about earlier this
morning
and joining us live we have gabby who is
store manager here to talk to us about
all right first of all what's the big
concept here besides
taking pictures and enjoying the
beautiful colors here
every guest pretty much comes out with
their own experience so that's the point
everyone comes out happier just in a
better mood
and you get creative so that's what we
encourage tell us about the room you're
in right now
yeah it's our tropical forest room it
pretty much gives a really really good
tropical vibration where it just gives
you
the mood of just relaxation
you were telling me the other two
locations are
one in beverly hills two in hollywood
and number three in las vegas now
yeah this is our third location we did
really well with our opening at
beverly in hollywood so we brought it
here in vegas and it's doing quite well
we do appreciate the locals and and
tourists that do come in
and on that now can you just briefly
explain how you guys are
integrating local artists too we were in
a room earlier yes we did
we're working with a local artist named
adam roller and his artwork is going to
be displayed until february 6th
we're actually looking forward to his
new displays after that for the rest of
february
gabby thank you so much for having us
before you guys open
so there is your inside look here at the
museum of dream space for now reporting
live hector mejia
sherry i'll be waiting for you here
wow i'm going to bring my glasses just
because some of that's a little too
psychedelic for me
but i think it's really awesome and it's
photo opportunity
everywhere you look hector that is
really neat thank you
i love the moon that's neat john isn't
it cool and they even added the echo
effect to hector's voice
voice voice so you can hear here hear
him at the venetian vision
and cmc